Stassi Schroeder and Kristen Dodie fired
from Vanderpump rules after past races
actions against Bates towers resurfaced
hit the ceiling for me and made me
really want to run for the hills lane um
Kristen and Stassi decided they were
going to call the cops on me this is
when I quit like I left the show with a
body bag but you know tell my truth but
decided it wasn't gonna do anything for
me so I not human faith recently shared
that experience on Instagram live
recalling how Stassi and Kristen falsely
attempted to identify her as a woman
police were looking for in a string of
robberies that Instagram live led to a
call for action from the network
ultimately leading to the dismissal of
og stars Stassi and Kristen from the
show as well as newer cast mates max
boyens and Brett Caprio knee whose own
racist tweets resurfaced at the start of
season 8 it was might be one that's
attack attack attack attack in fact like
you know I was falling and I was this
not was that calling me names Sam I hear
it was Maddie's et sat down with faith
in 2018 after she left Vanderpump rules
even though she was still very much a
part of the show at the center of a
cheating scandal involving Jax Taylor I
get it look you're upset and I
understand that you know you probably
went in blitz pain on me this interview
happened around the same time that
Stassi and Kristen we're making those
false claims against me
sorry okay
so they're doing great it was just um it
was just tough because the social media
is supposed to be this platform where
you can help others and show people your
life in what's tough getting the
backlash where it's hurt they do their I
can act tough it out like it doesn't
bother me it bothers me
both Stassi and Kristen issued apologies
to faiths on Sunday Stassi writing in
part quote what I did to faith was wrong
I apologized and I do not expect
forgiveness I'm also sorry to anyone
else that feels disappointed in me I'm
going to continue to look closer at
myself and my actions and Kristen in
part said quote although my actions were
not racially driven I am now completely
aware of how my privilege blinded me
from the reality of law-enforcement
treatment of the black community and how
dangerous my actions could have been to
her I'm ashamed embarrassed and
incredibly sorry
I would hope what happens to me never
happens to anyone else I'm sure well
when I create a guy that's happened
anyone else in it's actually made me
stronger which a lot of things in my
life have made me stronger so I have a
lot of other things going on thank God
you know I kept my mind to other things
and I have God on my side I got my
family on my side I hope you guys join
my side at some point come to come to
the light yeah but it all works out in
the end
[Music]